[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
les gens s'en vont ceux qui sont formés
ne viennent plus on a un mal de chien à
recruter parce que les conditions de
travail sont délétères c'est à dire que
y'a plus de vie de famille darty est
peut-être plus les hôpitaux mais en les
structures sociales qui fonctionne le
week-end et la nuit c'est pareil on est
rappeler constamment sur les repos les
vacances les délais et cetera parce
qu'effectivement la grotte de la grande
difficulté c'est qu'il faut faire
tourner 24 24 les structures et ça on
peut plus depuis maintenant trois ans on
nous balade on nous fait des promesses
et ses gentilles nous applaudir c'est
gentil de reconnaître notre engagement à
chaque discours devant le parlement mais
ça ne suffit pas nous ce qu'on veut
c'est du concret